Now new video tonight in a deadly
motorcycle accident as authorities ask
for your help in solving a crime a Las
Vegas man died this past Wednesday
following a hit run in Centennial Hills
at North Durango in the 215. Ryan
Matthew joining us tonight from nhp
headquarters Ryan has the very latest
well Brian it's been over two days and
the Tomas family has no answer still
like who was the other driver involved
in this Collision why didn't they stop
to help and could that have saved this
man's life while the family waits for
those answers from State Police State
Police asking for the Public's help
he took my brother he was only 27. only
27 my younger brother the Tomas family a
member sure son brother and father Tony
Tomas dying after his motorcycle
collided with a van they're not asking
you know is he alive and they just
looked at me like just stared at me with
blank faces his mother Ginger Patterson
says a stranger pulled over to perform
life-saving measures the original driver
speeding off that one minute could have
saved his life the hospital's a minute
away
family remember the 27 year old like
this free on his motorcycle with the
Aloha Spirit the solar installer was
known by the nickname Hawaii by the
local biking Community who gathered
Thursday night at the scene of the crash
to remember him seriously like he was a
kind person
he didn't deserve this his sister
Samantha Tomas joining her mother at the
scene for hours before watching his body
be taken away they say their grieving is
twofold we don't know we don't know we
don't even know the person if he was
drunk the only video evidence this
suspected white utility van with damages
to the back right side last seen here at
Elkhorn and Grand Montecito the family
left pleading for justice please turn
yourself in I will forgive you
groups of him I would ask the courts to
know your sentence just turn yourself in
now they say if anything they hope this
Collision brings awareness to reckless
driving on our roads now State Police
they're asking anybody with potential
information on this or may have seen
that white vehicle to contact them via
star 647 or you can do so anonymously
with the Crime Stoppers hotline number
you just saw on your screen reporting
live outside nhp headquarters Ryan
Matthey 8 News Now